[Music]
like
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
I'm gonna lie
the lovers
[Music]
you
good morning Millennials welcome back to
the morning toast happy Tuesday the week
is moving nice and slow but I like to be
just the way we like it
how's everyone doing today everyone's
doing well uh always tired but you know
me here excited to be here honored to be
you know just the host of the most
prestigious morning show in America I
and and outline you know properties and
outer boroughs and territory and outer
territories thank you I couldn't think
of the word yes and you know we are
international as well
okay I'm usually you we did get I was
checking our merch analytics we did get
one order from Saudi Arabia so our Saudi
Arabian toaster like please show
yourself you know I'm serious yeah
totally one I hope she got the flag yeah
I haven't seen actually no I saw one
picture of the flag at like a Jimmy
Buffett concert with some other like
intense looking flash Jimmy Buffett a
toaster I think so that's what I've
heard
yeah I haven't seen a bunch of premium
content of the flag so show sirs please
assemble yes information anyways welcome
back to the show yes usually it has been
a journey since last episode I know well
we did with Tamra and Eddie by the way
Eddie was such a surprise like we didn't
even know he was coming Tamra was just
pitch to us but I was so honored to have
them both
I know Satan they're really a cute
couple and she is so beautiful she's so
tiny
he doesn't do her justice and billing a
TV does not do her justice like
sometimes when you need a housewife like
you see them in person they don't look
like human like do you know what I mean
like she is I snatched but also human
like and she just looked adorable and
easy breezy and I was impressed and
those Gucci pumps like I definitely did
a quick Google search afterwards it's
definitely inspired da Tay I've got my
nineties morning show host look going
today I've got like my emo teenager like
mommy ruining my life dress on yeah but
think you also had to go to a college
interview see pull your hair back yeah
pull my hair back and like slicked it up
with some pomade because I'm just on a
natural hair kick to speak and we're
just gonna see where it takes us as a
society and that's a choice because
probably because you're so busy I would
say I'm so busy I might have to worry do
not have proper plumbing to take a
shower right I do I'm really living in
like a sewage fest I have asbestos and
sewage fest I heard that's where courts
know
it's like they couldn't pull off
Woodstock so they're putting on sewage
fest and it's taking place in my
apartment all the modes mold spuds are
getting together it's asbestos season
it's just so treacherous I've been
apartment hunting because they're gonna
be looking like they're gonna have to
tear up my whole apartment it's just
been such a journey and I had two
glasses of wine that saying like you
know I don't drink wine and like I
totally understood like why people like
why did you know any mean but it's
usually like I'll get wine and then like
five minutes later I get a headache yeah
I got wine and I had a headache three
hours later so it should be yeah right
before bed and I'm feeling sprightly I
feel like you know they say you should
have one glass of wine for your heart
like my heart's feeling pumping yeah
you've got a lot of catching up to do
I've got a lot of catching up to do I'm
also got a lot of catching up to do with
the universe because the world didn't
stop spinning we reported fast five
stories yesterday but so much happened
the world was shutting jivin Jeffrey
Epstein is he alive he made his way all
the way to the Cayman Islands like
what's happening I don't know yeah you
guys I went down such a deep dark rabbit
hole yesterday looking at Jeffrey
Epstein conspiracies like I landed in a
place that I think like now the
government is surveilling me yeah for
sure like you are his mole no but it was
worth it I feel like I got a lot more
information we're gonna talk more about
it today and I don't think we're gonna
stop talking about it until we have some
[ __ ] answers let me take a trip this
oh wait let's take a trip to his island
and let's just [ __ ] find him well you
know the FBI was there yesterday there's
all these like Julian pictures of them
unlike the water is like that Turks and
Caicos like blue but you're in there FBI
squad jackets I got it they're finally
ready the island oh not to look for him
to look for evidence for the case but
it's like [ __ ] you're late yeah there
was anything there it's not there anyway
no every obscene managed to escape
prison he also managed to clean up his
island hit it wasn't a maid he sent glue
zine where the [ __ ] is she that's what
everyone's talking about let's ask our
rats well shall we she goes okay so I
feel like find my friends on I feel as
though that's a great way yeah because
it's our first story so without further
ado here are the fast five stories that
you need to know before you wake up and
take a bite out of your morning toast
now I know that we have a lot to do and
I promise you we are going to take it by
that of our morning shows but literally
like my heart is in shambles at the
thought
my heart is broken into a million pieces
devastated mourning the loss if I didn't
tell you by said today's episode is
brought to you by Felix gray whoa you
may not realize it but the average
American blasts their eyes with bright
screens for 11 hours every day when you
consider how much our day revolves
around our devices it doesn't seem so
crazy but you can protect your eyes from
all that extensive screen time with a
pair of Felix gray blue light filtering
glasses available in both a non
prescription and prescription glasses
screen time phone on my app is really
like got me aware of how much I'm on my
device I'm up to twelve and a half hours
a day it's not crazy that's [ __ ] up no
I know so the field and I do feel like
when I go to sleep my eyes are burning
and it takes me longer to fall asleep
because of all the stimulation of the
blue light in my eyes I'm sure
so the glasses that I wear I'm just like
around the house or if it looks gray and
I feel as though it's counteracting all
the blue lights stigmatism that are
penetrating my eyeballs no it's quite
important especially for someone like
you who spends in half their day and I
bet you didn't know the majority of
Americans live with tired dry eyes
blurry vision or headaches caused by
screens if this sounds familiar if you
look straight glasses are for you they
filter out 90% of high-energy blue light
and eliminate 99% of glare coming
through from your daily barrage of
screens
unlike other blue light filtering
glasses Felix Craig uses proprietary
blue light technology embedded into the
lens as opposed to a cheap coating that
can easily chip or scratch over time
don't go another day looking at screens
without the help of some Felix gray
glasses go to felix great glasses
dot-com / toast for free shipping and 30
days of risk-free returns or exchanges
so you can get glasses with prescription
if you have bad eyesight or you can just
get the glasses without a prescription
to protect your eyes at Felix grey
glasses calm that's fel ixg are a why
glasses calm / toast
check it out 30 days of risk free
returns free shipping as well that's a
deal love it okay now switching gears
I'll tell you who didn't have this Felix
gray glasses Geoffrey up Steph free
Epstein when he was watching all the
footage that he took of other people
having sex with underage girls so he
could blackmail them later in life and
maybe use that as a way to escape from
prison because his friends knew that he
needed them
FBI agents swarmed Geoffrey Epstein's
private Caribbean island FBI agents
raided Jeffrey Epstein private island in
the Caribbean on Monday and I love when
the headline is like the same exact
sentence it's the first sentence of the
so it's like I know Jackie and Claudia
are superstars superstars Jackie and
Claudia let's you to repeat yourself
and now I know like which sources do
that in which tones so I kind of they're
good but today we're at um NBC News not
a reusable for us no that's not a usual
for us at all look at us one hop skip
and a jump from the Today Show yeah I
mean they this technically this is Miz
news but then while I was down
controversy was lame I learned that it's
right off of Wisteria Lane allegedly
Jeffrey Epstein is not a finance here at
all someone made him like was be like a
puppet of a financier to organize all of
this who knows who that someone is and
who like made him be a stage financier
so but how would unlike no one has ever
spoken to him about like treason or
anything he hasn't given anyone any
stock tips no and he was no one's
businessmen though well so if that's the
case like how would he have purchased a
private island like someone gave him the
money yes so he was really just like a
loser who wanted friends and did illegal
things for his friends so they would
think he was cool potentially this
sounds like the beginning of a walk to
remember you could still be that even if
he was a financier just a loser who did
thanks to his writings that illegal
things so that his friends but if he was
really like this puppet like that
literally reminds me of the opening
scene of a walk to remember but like
you're just gonna do anything to be with
the cool kids yeah
pedophilia included so there's someone
worse than Jeffrey Epstein definitely oh
for sure over here like if we know about
Jeffrey Epstein then he's bad but he's
not the worst like the ones that we
don't know about like the people whose
names aren't even in the press like
those are the most evil people yeah yeah
the people who helped him escape from
prison apparently there was a guard that
night watching him who's not a regular
like guard at the Correction Center I
guess it was good clothes ain't no and
it sounds like you're saying sir Gregor
Clegane
that's what I think but from Game of
Thrones I think you're getting confused
cuz her name is Maxwell talking about
blue haze he's his brothel corn maze
he's sorcerer his under sorceress her
cure I thought you were saying for sure
of underage me yeah got it
FBI agents raided Jeffrey Epstein's
private island in the Caribbean on
Monday in a vivid display that the probe
into his alleged sex trafficking ring is
continuing despite his death a swarm of
federal agents was seen fanning out
across little st. James in golf carts
30 a.m. it's just the craziest sight to
see like you know the FBI like they're
great jackets on little fisherman boats
to get to the island yeah
we were just trying to look at pretty
fish and swim with turtles and here we
are in the middle of an FBI raid said
Kelly Quinn the owner of salty dog day
snails oh my god I thought that was the
statement of like an FBI person who's
routing the sailing charter in the area
quote this has been something on our
radar for years Quinn added we're all
really curious why it's happening now
exactly Jackie so Gregory and her name
is Maxwell Gillan it's nuts how explain
Maxwell Neelu Maxwell okay I liked how I
said if I look sir gregor clegane
Maxwell hey it's on Astor so Miss Greg
Urkel Glenn Maxwell I agree
anyways this is way too little too late
like not only did he already plead
guilty to like prostitution years ago
he's had so much time to clean up a
majority of evidence I think this island
is now deserted
I mean maybe they'll find like a candy
bar wrapper there with like DNA on it
but I who gives a flying [ __ ] but now
it's like what is the island going to
become because if someone I was gonna
buy and like making their home for their
kids like Richard Branson like what do
you do with an island that was owned by
a billionaire financier which is now a
crime scene and probably the home to a
ton of pedophilia like what does what's
next for this island um I think it'll go
for sale at a big discount yeah and you
know that's exciting
whoever gets it and like if you are like
rich but like not owning an island rich
like maybe you could own this island and
at that point it's like you know
memories are short I'm not you know I'm
not one to benefit off of you know
pedophilia but I do feel as though like
now it's time for me to buy an island if
there was ever time if there was ever a
time I love a discount yeah love when
things go on sale I think this could be
it for me I think so too
I also am just we need answers we need
answers and I feel like between us like
Andy is not gonna let this go
no not at all the New York Post I've
been getting my paper every single day
it's on the cover they are not gonna let
this go there's and I feel like the
people have really are all in agreement
that there's no way on God's green
diddly Dalia's though this was a suicide
I said I was strong you know Jackie like
I can't even I can't even say that like
that I refused to give that theory any
sort of merit merit and it's actually
like insulting and harmful when the
papers and the press say like a parent
suicide like you why don't you say death
because it's not a suicide it hasn't
been ruled a suicide
the coroner hasn't they've done they're
doing their autopsies they haven't come
to a conclusion yet so like just say
death why are you guys putting out there
suicide like waiting on I haven't been
announced you have to assume if the
people who want a Jeffrey Epstein dead
could arrange him to be killed in prison
they can also arrange the autopsy to
show what they wanted to show and the
media to say what they want us to say
even now Cooper could do that exactly
and if I was Cooper can do it so can the
Clintons yeah do you like who do you
actually think was behind us honestly I
think it's someone whose name I don't
know right I don't think it's the Queen
I don't think it's someone so I can you
know I don't know I'm so visible would
commit a murder at the most visible time
right and it's it's a person who has the
most to lose because they haven't been
implicated yet like no one's thinking
that they're a part of this pedophilia
ring they're continuing to live their
lives and I also don't think that it was
necessarily one person and like the
person who might have committed the
murder like could have been I don't know
if it was d'Alene in a wig posing as a
guard
or a fellow cellmate who you know these
businessmen both ought to go pay your
fat you move to the island yeah you'll
get the island I do I'm gonna say that
it was ghilane Maxwell in the cell with
the knife ya know with the Chokey no but
Kelly's his friend actually I don't
think she would kill him but she too has
lots to lose yeah but no one's been able
to find her did you see what Bethany
tweeted no when it was all like maybe
like a month ago when we were really in
the thick of the Jeffrey Epstein of it
all and all these information was coming
about about dealing Maxwell sheets like
this procure of whatever I'm Bethany was
like I met her once I'm assuming she had
to have met her with Carol and she said
she was so rude to me like I wasn't
famous or interesting enough for her to
talk to now who's laughing
but when Bethenny was friends with Carol
she was super famous and super
interested what ghilane is like part of
the Google the crew like he is really
like hi she the people she talks to our
like George Clooney
yeah so for her I bet Real Housewife is
like well actually she spends with Carol
but you know what I mean Carol was
Kennedy so yes she's and now I princess
okay well we'll continue to update you
with the questions that we have
regarding this story all I'm saying is
something's not right
yeah something smells fishy fishy
okay next story Liam Hemsworth has
broken his silence regarding his divorce
for Miley Cyrus and while he's broken
his silence I've broken my heart to a
million pieces yes he posted a beautiful
picture of sunset I think he might have
been using Jackie O flow Jannetty
honestly that looks like some like
old-school like camera plush it agreed
this looks like like maybe the cha-cha
filter yes where this guy is like a deep
blue whatever just saying hi all just a
quick note to say that Miley and I have
recently separated and I wish her
nothing but health and happiness going
forward this is a private matter and I
have not made nor will I be making any
comments to any journalists or media
outlets any reported quotes attributed
to meet our false peace and love so I
guess he didn't say yeah that thing that
he didn't want to talk about it yeah and
he was like that it's like I love my
editor made there to make it seem
authentic yeah it worked for me um I
mean this just adds to yesterday's wine
of thinking of this being just like so
utterly devastating and it's really
clear that like Liam did not want this
you know what I mean and he was the one
who got broken up with he was the dumpee
Miley was the dumper
he's I really hope he's just leaning on
Chris's shoulder you know because he's
home in Australia with family so I'm
sure Chris is there with his big
shoulder you know it's like when you
think of like the best shoulder in the
world to cry on like I think of like the
tan warm supple skin of Chris
Hemsworth's enormous shoulder
yeah of Thor yes the word right like
what better children to cry on and I
feel like Jason Momoa has got a pretty
oh yeah you know what but I do feel as
though his hair would get in the way Oh
Kevin sort has none of that
that's Cheryl so Chris OH does does
Jason Momoa I have kids of his own yes
yes so when you're when you're a father
you're like cradling nurturing arms too
so that definitely helps it definitely I
I think that Jason Momoa and Chris
Hemsworth my
have two bachelors in industry yeah
they're but they're the best shoulders
like in each of their hemispheres yeah
cuz they're totally different once why
Australia yeah so like we need a
shoulder in North America and we need a
shoulder in Australia
we're like Miley she's out in LA she has
Jason Momoa shoulder to cry on and
because Chris Hemsworth is out in
Australia with his brother Liam Liam has
Chris's shoulder line yeah
Miley's actually in Italy but she is
Caitlin John you know and that is not a
good small as a shoulder it's so small
and like sharp you know with a collar
but we're just like slice your neck
right off okay you have a good shoulder
to cry on it's it's usually warm
sometimes I you know I do get vo
sometimes so maybe it's not the best
actually very fair I don't I don't think
you want to cry I don't think so I know
it's I know it's far out and I don't
think that Liam Hemsworth should be
moving forward and anytime that he's not
comfortable with but you know you can't
help a question who's next
of course and I just I just wanted to
put it out there that yes I'm a married
woman but I am still available I know
something I feel like he knows them like
you guys have Todd no and it's like you
know what was your Oh like you're like
Hannah Jane tired I think you're open
yeah and it's like when you're connected
with someone like you don't even have to
say it you know like I feel like you can
feel what I'm feeling a hundred percent
yeah so he just needs time and then
he'll find his way back but it's almost
like I don't want him to find anyone cuz
I really feel as though him and Miley
we're like endgame you know what I'm
officially off the train like it's been
too much and this seemed like anytime
they broken up in the past it was
understandable two different directions
but then they got married and divorced
there's they're not gonna get back
together after a divorce and also like
the way she is being in Italy right now
I I don't know what happened between
them but it's just he's certainly sad
and she's just like parading around with
her new flame and I don't I want
different for him not better not worse I
just want something different yeah
Magritte point it is really
disrespectful like it's not like they
broke up boyfriend/girlfriend like this
is like a ten-year relationship and a
marriage and just to be like you know
you're right you're totally right also
did you see that Brody Jenner said that
he knew about Miley and Kaitlyn's
relationship and he was the one who
introduced them so like I feel as though
maybe this was going on like I don't
know that this was the catalyst I know I
don't think that this was the cat
I do actually think like Miley and Liam
are on two separate pages like
completely in their lives and their
careers and like Miley's like one of
those girl she's a wild child and she's
been tamed but I think she ultimately
and she tried to tell you tried to tell
her that she can't be tamed but but I
can't be tamed
she's like she changed she literally
told us so as much as like she was like
you know really settling down with him
that wild side was always kind of
peeking out and wouldn't you know us
wild girls we just we can't be we can't
be put in a box you know yeah but I feel
like Ben deals with it better than Liam
like he's just you know really serious
so like Liam just doesn't you know
appear to me to be one of the guys who
like can handle a girl who's just like a
little nuts no but and he was he was
doing it I don't know the good thing is
that I don't think Liam will have a hard
time bouncing back no but he I think
you're gonna be a why I'm like what
she's annoying for us like he's gonna be
sad for a long time you know and because
he's such a good guy
he who Emsworth his parents like they're
all good guys mr. and mrs. Hemsworth and
you know I just want to take a moment of
appreciation and serve justice for the
third one whose name I literally think
Luke he's not yeah get the worst big
gavel and justice it up he's just not it
sis and i wiii iose OCA ssin that's true
he's got like your kids could be it
because genetic makeup to thor
yeah that is exciting okay next story
interests and news from Todd chrisley
who took to Instagram to say I've never
talked about this publicly before but
there's been a cloud hanging over
Julianne me and our entire family for
the past seven years it all started back
in 2012 when we discovered that a
trusted employee of ours had been
stealing from us big-time I won't go
into details but involved all kinds of
really bad stuff like creating phony
documents forging their signatures and
threatening other employees with
violence if they said anything we even
discussed it discovered that he
illegally bugged our home needless to
say we figured we fired the guy and took
him to court and that's when the real
trouble started to get revenge she took
a bunch of his phony documents to the US
Attorney's Office and told them we had
committed all kinds of financial crimes
like tax evasion and bank fraud that got
their attention alright but once we had
a chance to explain who he was and what
he done to us they realized it was a
bunch
nonsense and sent him on his way so it
looks like they're gonna be indicted for
tax evasion and other financial crimes
and so he's trying to get in front of it
but I would say the most interesting
part of this whole story is their oldest
daughter who he's like she's like part
of the family but she's been always like
a little bit of strange I would assume
even more strange now because she
tweeted something very interesting when
all that when he put up his post why did
his father last name Chris Lee yeah
Chris Ellie why she posted something we
shot everything
Lindsay here she said your next season
is going to cause some people to wish
they had treated you better was that
mean that person probably is gonna go
down but sounds like a nice thing to say
oh I thought it was me and I am it's
very confusing yeah well I just have to
say I don't know if this is true like if
they committed tax evasion or if it's
like a big you know elaborate scheme by
this one anonymous in place but their
financials have always been really weird
when we first came on the show they
lived in this [ __ ] huge house and
actually recently we watched the first
episode of Chris Lee and I can't believe
the show got picked up one because it's
horrible and two because he's talking
about how he wants to open a department
store called Chris Lee's in Atlanta like
make it the next Neiman Marcus but he
does want to sell anything over above a
size four because he just doesn't like
those types of women and like know if
like his wife what his wife literally
sat there what are you talking about
she's like a size six or an eight like
it was so stupid but there have their
financials are very confusing because
they had this big up house and when we
met them he like wasn't working in real
estate anymore he wanted to open a
department store which made no sense
then we never good about the department
store again he never like really went
back to work and then they downsized to
it like still a nice house but a smaller
house just talking about how like he
want to be closer to his mom or
something so there and as long as
they've been on TV like I've never
actually seen him go to work yeah I just
don't know today that his name's not
Chris Chris Lee so Chris Lilley you're
thinking no I just thought there was a
Chris Chris Lee like honestly this this
their family seems like the type of TV
show that Chris Lilley would actually do
a parody of I've actually never watched
their show I know you have like a thing
against it and I've watched it I know I
think I tried one episode when it first
came and I just thought he was so mean
yeah I think why am i watching a mean
guy then there's other shows out in the
very beginning like it never should have
gone picked up like he was so weird and
like even the show was like all about
him I'm like you're a grown [ __ ] man
like give your kids a show like he was
just it was like he would make his
daughter sweet 16 like about him it was
so stupid he was like a child running
around but no is he to begin with right
so if he's the famous person understand
he makes things about you but like
you're just a dad they made it seem like
he was a very wealthy real estate mogul
but I've never actually seen anything of
his rolls have people working for them
who don't commit tax fraud no moguls
have people working for them who take
the fall for their pedophilia rings yeah
take the fall for their tax for our not
set them up for it it's just it's such a
weird story like so basically he
announced like we wouldn't have known
about this indictment if he did make
this Instagram post
I'm sure the indictment will be coming
soon got it so he wants to get in front
of it just falling into the category
with Abby Lee Miller and the situation
were people of reality stars who didn't
pay their but this doesn't make sense
because what he says is that the US
Attorney's Office and them spoke about
like this person impersonating them and
understood but they're also saying that
there probably is gonna be an indictment
so did the US Attorney's Office agree
with you or not he persuaded this guy a
different set of investigators of the US
Attorney's Office not only to reopen the
case but also to grant him immunity from
prosecution I don't know it's like
that's how it works you know like if the
US Attorney decides not to prosecute
something I don't know that there's
someone else in the department you can
be persuaded you know they're just
talking about the u.s. departments
office like it's literally like a group
of like elementary school kids it's like
he wouldn't do it I found someone else
to do it like it's so stupid I know but
like after Jeffery I've seen like
anything's possible that's true
anything's possible this just doesn't
shock me whatsoever their financials
have always been so weird like they got
a show as pseudo rich people like it
make no sense so this is a long time
coming yeah but it's just sad because
like now they are famous and like
they're settled in their level of Fame
and like this is gonna throw a wrench in
it I hope the show does thing I can't
smoke it's like it just got interesting
I don't think shows getting cancelled
for tax evasion
yeah like pedophilia for sure
drug use pedophilia I've got honey
booboo cancelled animal
what God can't oh wow did you know
haven't got off Teen Mom yeah uh
interesting is just like to see as a
society where we draw the line
interesting okay our next story is quite
interesting I'm sure some people will be
excited by it
especially Claudia who is already
declared it autumn and I guess Starbucks
is watching because I'm sorry Dunkin
Donuts Oh is watching Dunkin Donuts has
a new drink for fall and it's coming for
the pumpkin spice latte and it will be
available starting Octus 21st wow so
they're getting in early and they're
coming for Starbucks it's official we're
in the dead middle of summer and the
pumpkin spice race has begun
who can say or overwhelm our pumpkin
spice cravings first last week's
Starbucks announced that the new PSL
creamer would join the rest of its
pumpkin spice products on grocery store
aisles everywhere and with its
conveniently placed p and its history
story of opportunistic rebranding it's
only a matter of time before I hop
renames itself and okay what refinery29
with there Duncan will debut its fall
menu on August 21st but first it wants
to get a head start on fall decor and
pumpkin celebration this season a Duncan
we can look forward to the return of
pumpkin doughnut and pumpkin muffin Plus
expect new additions like cinnamon sugar
pumpkins signature latte YUM apple cider
doughnut and munchkin doughnut holes ooh
looks like you're still telling them
munchkins some doughnuts a lot of work
to do yeah totally
don't let Donuts like still has a lot of
work to do because in terms of branding
like they're so like orange and autumn
vibes but like the Starbucks totally
owns the autumn market and it's kind of
at the mayor of autumn bill I feel as
though Dunkin Donuts we doing a better
job also is it true that Jonah's
rebranded she just Dunkin yeah I don't
miss exciting I don't think it's
sticking because everyone's still saying
techni doughnuts including refinery29
yeah it's confusing but I think the
biggest thing for the Dunkin rebound is
the fact that they will now have their
breakfast sandwiches with impossible
impossible meat which like I'm actually
wanna go get one let's go you know
there's no more time to dota2 the city
anymore no there are America runs on
Dunkin
yeah but like people that's
always been a funny slowly because like
they like push like the most unhealthy
products like all their drinks are so no
one's writing like we're all slowly
making our way to our local Dunkin we're
probably driving and doing the
drive-thru yeah American drives their
junk it's like a weird chain chain
because on the one hand it's like it's
the donut place like if it's your
birthday in your middle school like
you're picking up Duncan for the class
and like when you saw that parent
walking in with those two [ __ ] big
boxes of Jonah it's like you knew there
was like [ __ ] nothing better it's
gonna be the most like live day at
school yeah cuz you're having a doughnut
you're gonna just be on a sugar high
yeah and like honestly like if there's
seconds like you get there first you
know right I mean some people like
definitely we're tightening the belt and
went for munchkins still good good but
like at a school in a classroom there's
no place for much but like a third
grader eating a whole doughnut is
obscene like those things early yes it's
literally so much sugar so many calories
and like in these tiny third grader
bodies they deserved it like getting
through school was [ __ ] miserable as
big as you think yeah no no it's an
adult I feel as though a proper serving
form you know my weight and my BMI is
two doughnuts I don't think one would do
it for me anymore okay
it depends actually like Jugend donuts
there are they are good but they're
super like artificial tasting like it's
not like real strawberry you know but if
you go to Krispy Kreme I could be
suffice with one because they're so
delicious and heavy and like savory yeah
and then Duncan is it's when you get a
little bit older it's like you know the
copy place but like is there coffee good
no no no every single time I get an iced
coffee there tastes like absolute duty
and also an interesting factoid about
Dunkin Donuts it's more often than not
when I go to go to the donut city
usually and like a rest stop or like
when I'm out of town like just whatever
and it's oh wait they're always
splitting their rent with like a Baskin
Robbins people hide that way it seems
like they can't pay their rent yeah but
like America [ __ ] runs on Dunkin like
I feel like they're doing really well
it's not you know a mattress firm
situation no but people compare it to
being like Tim Hortons in Canada or
Krispy Kreme like the American bakery
and at the end of the day like I cannot
think of the last time I saw anyone I
know like carrying a cup of coffee from
Dunkin Donuts yeah well I think
Starbucks I think they need to focus on
their coffee yeah I think they need to
elevate a little bit like every
food brand has really elevated their
branding and their menu to like move it
like a little bit in a more healthy
direction or have more healthy options
or just like look more elevated like
judgment Otis has been serving they're
copying those same ugly fat styrofoam
cups since I was in third grade yeah
they really need like an elevated but
it's America it's a America runs on
Dunkin an America seems like happy
running on Dunkin but I'm not sure if
New York runs on Dunkin I definitely
think there are parts of America that
run on Dunkin I don't think New York
runs on Dunkin no New York runs on
Starbucks also I just think about the
feeling I have when I like if I'm in the
wild and I see a certain franchise you
know and I'm like starving and Dunkin I
would be so excited bout cuz the food
really is good and you can get coffee
I [ __ ] hate the coffee is worse and
the food is plastic when they need a
fast food chains it's important to think
of it if when you're on a road trip yeah
what in the moment what logo are you
happy to see and if I I would drive one
the Dean I would drive right past
Starbucks I was a bagel a doughnut or
something they sell Pepsi I would go to
Dunkin Donuts 100% agreed yeah that's a
good way to think about it actually I
went to I'm a rest stop in Connecticut
on my way to Vermont this weekend that
was like the most brand-new fancy
amazing rest stop and here here we're
what here's what they had ready that at
Chipotle McDonald's a Taco Bell a Sbarro
a Dunkin Donuts a candy store like it
was so [ __ ] premium and I want to get
your point late cuz I was like I'm gonna
be thin um lol how Chipotle is thin for
me and it was [ __ ] closed so I have to
get doughnuts from married oh that's
actually I did I got about sub functions
young munchkins are really [ __ ]
delicious yeah and they are a great size
for a third grader and what do they call
him a Tim Horton's murga memory aid them
okay oh oh k tune it's two bits wow that
was not there's not as good honestly and
I'm not just being like you know taking
the side of America I'm being very
diplomatic about it and it's not as good
understood well Duncan is in agreement
with you that fall is to come in follows
a comment and if you're there new
Sanford for the fall months like
something autumnal with like a hint of
maple yeah I think that you should
because you are the mayor of autumn I'm
the air bottom and it'll only be you
found like maple what perfumes have you
tried from said bird you know I really
can't talk
Bulgari thanks for asking have you tried
boy love it I take it with me I've been
traveling so much and I have this like
new fancy smell I have like my
pedestrian like New York smell and then
when I travel I'm like Sanford validated
am I trying all these new fragrances
December does luxury fragrance
subscription service for perfumes and
Cologne we've been talking about them
for a while I use them all the time like
a little spritz under the armpits and in
the hair can go an extremely long way on
a very long day a wait for you to
discover new perfumes that colognes
without having to Bayern buy an entire
bottle
more than four hundred and fifty
designer brands for you to choose from
they've got product time for adverse ace
Dolce CA Gracia Gucci Calvin Klein you
can choose the perm you want to try
they'll send you a 30-day supply so it's
basically like a mini bottle of perfume
it's 120 sprays it's enough to apply
more than four times a day for a month
and then the month is over and you can
choose a new one so I'm definitely gonna
go from like a more summery like floral
vibe until I come much more like heavy
autumnal like fall bad yeah you need to
find like pumpkin spice yes thats bird
you could check out user ratings for
every fragrance they have reviews or you
can take their true scent quiz to
discover more personalized
recommendations for your taste so you
can go in knowing what you want or they
can help you find what you want with an
exclusive offers for our listeners you
can get 50% off your first month today
at scent word.com slash toast that's
only seven dollars and fifty cents for
your first fragrance go to said bird
comm slash toast and sign up for 50% off
your first month and that's SCE MTBI our
d.com slash toast for you to try your
first perfume or cologne for just seven
dollars and fifty cents sign on smell
amazing
okay amazing it's exciting don't break
your iPad on the way down this is
because they smell amazing so true like
nothing matters when you smell amazing
and that's why everything always matters
for me okay baby by the story a little
business wait we need a corresponding
[ __ ] I just went like this and it
felt good like there's news
something really similar but I think it
felt better a little business I guess
it's like easier yeah like there's like
a little interpretive for me okay so I'm
a right arm down first right arm right
arm up okay okay
a little business you think we'd like do
like an ounce of preparation for the
show where we could have made that up
like offline you know yeah well you know
what now we're set for life Verizon
agrees to sell tumblr to the owner of
WordPress and this directly affects us
because we used to be co-workers with
the tumblr team like we were part of
Verizon they were part of fries and we
were all just like you know tumbling
around
we were we were like gymnasts just
tumbling our way through Verizon and I
find this story particularly interests
aunt because Verizon bought tumblr a few
years ago for over 1 billion dollars
AOL bought tumblr and then Verizon
bought AOL yes so it's like they it's
like the gaggle of loser companies
there's no Yahoo bought tumblr Oh God
AOL no and then Verizon bought AOL and
merged with Yahoo something we might
literally why did you put all the losery
companies in one place yes I mean one
LLC exactly until one and that's an
infinite yeah that's why they fired us
okay tumblr was acquired by Yahoo for
1.1 billion dollars in 2013 before
moving under Verizon's umbrella through
the carrier's acquisition of Yahoo in
2017 what is interest and is today it's
sold to the parent company of WordPress
for guess how much I already told you
guys can I could what were tell us give
us the backstory it was sold for
initially 1.1 billion dollars got it and
now it's being sold for drumroll please
three million dollars which begs the
question so I think I'm not a
mathematician but I I think they took a
loss yeah but it also begs the question
like if it's only three million dollars
why didn't like Taylor Swift buy it
she's pretty much single-handedly
keeping the app afloat like she and her
community
pretty much exists there solely and
there are people who literally only have
tumblr accounts for Taylor Swift myself
included so it seems like it actually
could have been maybe like a decent
investment for her I'm like she could
have turned it it's in her app yeah yeah
the other company that was interested in
buying
it was pornhub which also would have
been a great investment for them because
the people who aren't on tumblr for
Taylor Swift are there for porn yeah
maybe I shouldn't end a joint venture
yeah when I was on tumblr like back in
the day first I was no tumblr dude
starting girl with her job and then I
was just on tumblr like I used to pin
like country like pickup trucks and
stuff and it was like actually really
fun not pin you know what I mean yeah um
and I was ugly blog I was always finding
myself like literally watching porn it's
so it's everywhere it's just like you
new search like a cowboy what yeah
actually that makes sense but you know
anything yeah I understand my tumblr was
called
Darius Rucker phase I my tumblr was like
all like American flags I filled green
like pickup trucks and it was called
southern state of mind which is that
yeah
Darius Rucker that's so cool of you yeah
I thought it was cool but you know how
hard this if I like country inspo and
tumbler like that's not the vibe the
vibe is like rock on Avril Lavigne you
know yeah it's emo as house it's a motel
so I was like searching like American
flag cowboy boots you know did you find
any in spose super-hardened understood
but I wonder what will change now that
it's over at WordPress it'll probably
become maybe more of like a blog
actually I didn't even realize that
WordPress is actually like a great
parent company for that they can turn
tumblr around maybe worth it yeah and
they also need to like turn WordPress
around yeah you know WordPress kale now
my site is powered by WordPress exciting
very exciting ah so I just thought that
was a little interesting BAE's news you
know about a little interesting business
um about the unprofitability yeah no
it's just like now begs the question
what is arguably more valuable
tumblr or the morning toast the morning
toast that's right like that's a crazy
evaluation but I think it's like like
seven times your revenue or something I
have no idea no I have no idea how you
make a valuation yeah and so I don't we
don't make three million dollars but
we're definitely I feel as though we're
worth it you know yeah I feel as though
we are written - that is so low like I
can't believe it I'm almost like shocked
and I'm almost like not believing it
because I'm looking at this article in
my
newsletter they said it sold for three
million dollars not the only other of
your email newsletter uh it's a reported
three million dollars I guess that means
that it's not gonna be like three below
and it could be five right but it's
still on the board it could be one right
it could be less but it's still in the
ballpark isn't it just so crazy like
technologies are constantly evolving
yeah and like it's kind of worth noting
yet it's worth everything I watched a
trailer for a documentary that on data
and by watching the Jets
I watched trailer for documentary on
data I watched a trailer for a
documentary on data the documentary was
about date I thought you said I watch
the trailer for documentary like the
movie what's called documentary no okay
fair and by watching the trailer I just
watched it on data like on Netflix I was
so confused I learned that you know data
is just like big business it's
everything it's everything trillion
dollar industry and actually for the
first time is worth more than oil isn't
that praise on we need to get our data
like in a folder I don't know like and
yes I uh folder and just like put out my
David
I totally agree even that we should have
data up like do we yeah we we need to
get a new data analyst
come and like get our data like and just
like I want to physically see my data
just change can you analyze our data for
us do you think I don't even know what
that means
I know but like everyone but I think
that's the kind of data right no nobody
knows
has anyone ever like seen data like do
you know enemies no like when I used to
work in like a data-driven world like
for real that's like what it was like
doing like programmatic advertising
world people and maybe it was just me
who didn't understand it like the way
that people talk about data it's like
absolutely no one has any clue what
they're talking about you know and you
just talk about myself included yeah
nobody it was as though a clean house nu
e Jackie it's like cats the musical like
you just nobody knows what cat says you
just like saying I love yeah you just
keep yeah
interests at 11:11 make a wish I wish
for answers regarding Jeffery Epstein's
death murder escape interpretive I like
that and I wish for you know
next like the office is out of snacks
and I ate a [ __ ] Apple this morning
and you know everyone's like are you
hungry eat an apple no okay I was hungry
I was hungry I ate an apple and my I'm
still hungry
okay I'm living proof that that
statement is [ __ ] did you have it
yeah
they say that water expensive fibers and
AB let's make you feel more thumb I'm
[ __ ] starving when they have a fiber
one bar HIV drink water because I hope
that the fiber will expand yeah boiler
alerts it degree yes boiler if you're
reaching for an apple severs till the
time I go make a sandwich okay yeah I
would love a sandwich right now Jesus
sandwich or sandwich sandwich
is everyone still intermittent fasting
no I tried to start again I'm it's like
my and hoping this is what I'm doing
ready I'm just crossing my fingers and
hoping for the best honestly yeah I'm
eating when I'm hungry and try not to
even a monogram and see how it goes I
mean you're wearing like oh really like
Saudi little dress today and you look
great okay this dress is from Amazon and
I bought okay only like really like in
shape people can wear like thin dresses
like that from Amazon I called me in
shade yes you look really great
oh my god lady I just I I just like I
was inspecting you know like this sort
of like accolade like I'm I'm I'm like
I'm literally speechless like two
minutes we need a longest name alive by
the time you see me that's like I would
look rubdown and this dress will be
green understood well at least you'll
have the memento of CMS right now also
yeah it's long stay because we have to
record this match allure and I'm so
excited because I have so many thoughts
about bachelor in paradise last night
and I'm not gonna say any of them
because I just can't get into it except
for the fact that Mike Johnson tweeted
at us um he responded to our tweet about
Nicole's GoPro video wouldn't I just saw
that well what'd he say likes her lips
it was like weirdly flirty look through
us we were the vessel in which he
flirted you were the vessel in which he
flirted this morning so I was like so
shocked I had to make sure it was his
actual tweet we said oh my god you're
right mm-hmm he goes dead but like dead
emoji but she has cute lips
though so now I think they're engaged
now must be right
they must oh my god I'm dying that video
of Nicole was so funny I couldn't stop
well my god it was so funny I cannot
believe that Mike Johnson responds us
probably not okay definitely not but I'm
gonna follow him
maybe you know awaken him too to the
power um okay well that's all she wrote
thank you guys for an amazing day sorry
amahzing J I hope you guys have a great
day we'll see you tomorrow with Jenna
Ushkowitz and Kevin McHale from Glee and
they're promoting their new podcast
which is friendship based which is just
perfect for us it's so cute and then
Thursday Ben it's gonna be here filling
in for me because I am heading to
Virginia Beach and Richmond we have a
show tomorrow night in Virginia Beach
head over to girl throw job calm there's
still some tickets available and then
the night after that on Thursday we are
heading to Richmond at the noon I don't
know the name of the theater so I won't
say it also tickets available at
Carthage opcom come through Virginia
come through vagina um so yes tickets
available over the topic on Thursday Ben
will be here and then Friday we'll do a
podcast only episode because riding
around in Jersey for my show and ask for
a park on Saturday no tickets available
sorry actually there might be like one
or two I don't know check it out girl
time chapter comm I think that's what
the web sites called
how about ready I brought to you by
tumblr thank you guys for being here the
Milenio morning show we go live Monday
through Friday 10:30 a.m. Eastern Time
on YouTube we're also available it's
podcast so if you're listening on
YouTube
give this video a thumbs up subscribe
you know the whole shebang also head
over to that podcast store on iTunes on
Spotify stitcher I Heart Radio Public
Radio literally anywhere you listen to
Spotify leave a review subscribe saying
the review like oh my god these girls
are amazing they're so smart they're
always well researched and always look
beautiful they never have frizzy hair I
would really appreciate that other than
that there's nothing much else to say
except see you tomorrow bye Oh
tomorrow's episode is earlier than usual
yes sorry because me tomorrow off too I
hope we didn't cut the stream are we
good
realize so because me and Margo have a
show in Virginia Beach but I didn't want
to miss Jenna Ushkowitz and Kevin McHale
because the Gleek and me would never
forgive me we are gonna be live at 9:30
tomorrow they'll be joining us around 10
o'clock so be extra early Sager alarms
given its a tee at the wallet Hulu like
just do what you gotta do okay tomorrow
is actually the morning toast
you know it's so
it's so early I forgot about that like
after today's the glow along to say my
life and then have to make up even
earlier tomorrow yep
the hustle you just gotta grind it out
do what they say about the hustle never
stops never stops see you tomorrow bye
[Music]
you